If you do anything creative like program or design or write,...
...you know that it's hard to keep your creative energy up and stay focused.
Something as simple as a meeting scheduled here...
...will break your afternoon into two pieces...
...which are both too small to do anything creative in.
And the rest of your day is blown.
When you know your entire day is free, you soar like a creative eagle;...
...yet people are constantly asking to get things scheduled in,...
...even when those meetings are not important to what you're creating.
What you need to do is plan your day like a maker.
You see, managers rule the world...
...and they go from meeting to meeting no sweat.